a second whistleblower comes forward in
the Trump impeachment saga Rudy Giuliani
and president Trump play defense and
Chuck Todd goes off I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Fenton
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today and
expressvpn dot-com / Ben all righty so
the big news of the day is that a second
whistleblower has now come forward who
everyone is so excited a second
whistleblower now the first
whistleblower didn't have a lot to say
other than what was actually in the
transcript of the Ukraine phone call
remember this whistleblower the first
whistleblower turned out to be a
registered Democrat who was working
inside the intelligence community was a
CIA officer and it looks a lot like that
whistleblower was working in cahoots
with Adam Schiff on the House
Intelligence Committee and the two of
them were sort of playing an
inside-outside game now whether that's
the fault of the whistleblower or
whether that just means that the aide to
Adam Schiff was passing the information
along to Adam Schiff and he was then
pressing for information from the
outside the whole thing looked at least
a little bit fishy well now we have a
second whistleblower woo how exciting a
second so what do we know about this
second whistleblower as it turns out not
much here's what the associate
Associated Press reports today a second
whistleblower has come forward with
information about President Donald
Trump's dealings with Ukraine adding to
the impeachment peril engulfing the
White House and potentially providing
new leads to Democrats in their
unfurling investigation of Trump's
conduct now here's the thing what could
a whistleblower even say at this point
that would radically shift the case well
presumably the whistleblower could say
that they have evidence that Donald
Trump specifically said that he was
creating a quid pro quo for the purposes
of getting Joe Biden not merely
targeting corruption generally in Joe
Biden as an aspect of that but to get
Joe Biden regardless as to whether Joe
Biden was guilty or not and that this
whistleblower had actual first-hand or
hearsay knowledge that Trump had said
this directly to somebody and that's not
what the whistleblower is saying how I
remember the first whistleblower we
already have the transcript so what is
the second whistleblower gonna say that
the first one didn't attorney mark Syed
represents both whistleblowers he said
in a text message to the AP that the
second person has spoken to the ICS as
the intelligence community's internal
watchdog and can corroborate information
the original whistleblower complaint
which
like what is in there aside from the
transcript of the poem call and stuff
that we already sort of know from the
text messages between kurt volker who is
the special envoy to ukraine and gordon
sunland who is the US ambassador to the
European Union and Bill Taylor who is
the temporary ambassador to the Ukraine
look we already know all that stuff
because all those texts will release so
what can the second whistleblower
actually do other than just sort of add
fuel to the fire because whistleblower
whistleblower we're all we are all very
fond of this term whistleblower and that
means that they must have something
relevant to say well what if there's not
all that much there we're gonna find out
because who the hell knows what this
whistleblower has to say I'll explain in
just one second first there's a lot of
talk of impeachment obviously in
Washington trade wars with China the Fed
cutting the interest rate a perfect
storm is brewing for a rally and gold
and rally is currently taking place if
this house of cards that our economy is
built on collapse today would you be
protected what would be your plan I've
been telling you about precious metals
IRAs and Birch gold group for years now
they're part of my family's plan see if
they should be part of your family's
plan I'm not saying take all your money
and shove it into some gold bars and
bury it in your backyard I'm talking
about having some of your money
diversified into precious metals Birch
gold will go to work and make things
super simple for you they have a
conversation with you and you can
determine if precious metals make sense
for you ask all your questions get all
the information there's no obligation
say have nothing to lose to take that
first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau again having some
precious metals as a hedge against
inflation on certainty chaos and markets
it's just a good idea text Ben - 47 47
47 today to see how simple and
straightforward this move can be for you
again that is Ben - 47 47 47 text the
number Ben well the name Ben - 47 47 47
texts Ben - 47 47 47 okay so as The
Associated Press reports the new
whistleblower is apparently just gonna
corroborate with the first of all so
bloater said well we already have all
the documents so I'm not sure exactly
what the new whistleblower is gonna say
apparently the new whistleblower works
in the intelligence field and has
first-hand knowledge of key events so I
guess that could change things I mean if
they if the whistleblower is not just
speaking on third-hand now much like the
first whistleblower but actually has
heard Trump say something that might
change something the emergence of the
second whistleblower threatened to
undermine arguments from
and his allies to discredit the original
complaint they've called the politically
motivated claims it was filed improperly
and dismissed said it's unreliable
because it was based on secondhand or
third-hand information now as you'll
know if I'm listening to the show I have
never claimed that the actual
whistleblower complaint was deeply
unreliable in fact it seemed mostly
accurate the big problem with the
whistleblower complaint is whether it
actually represented something that was
truly troubling whether it represented
something that was that was truly
impeachable I shouldn't say truly
troubling so I'm troubled by it I am I'm
troubled by President Trump going to
Ukraine and then throwing Joe Biden's at
name out there because obviously it
raises the ugly specter of the President
of the United States pass so even
possibly putting pressure on a foreign
country to investigate a domestic
political opponent that's not something
you wanted to lightly and then when
President Trump goes out there and
doubles down on it and says things like
maybe China should go investigate you of
it like that doesn't help that doesn't
help the reason it doesn't help is
because Trump's entire defense right now
his entire defense rests on something
very simple which is he is saying I was
targeting corruption in Ukraine and thus
all of my threats to withhold aid all of
my threats to keep Vice President pens
from meeting with zalenski the president
of Ukraine all of my threats are not to
meet with zelanski myself oh that was
predicated on my desire to fight
corruption and Joe Biden that's because
you know listen that stuffs corrupt
right hunter Biden I think it's corrupt
Purisima it's corrupt and so I told them
investigate that as an aspect of broader
corruption investigations now that only
works if you believe that Trump's
primary or main or even admixed
motivation passage of corruption if you
actually believe that Trump wanted to go
after Biden and that all the corruption
stuff is basically just nonsense that he
added on top it's sort of a facade and
you rip away the facade and all that's
there is his desire to get Biden
well that's impeachable but if he's
ripping on corruption well frankly that
is what Joe Biden did right I mean Joe
Biden did in fact threaten to withhold 1
billion dollars in loan aid to Ukraine
contingent on Ukraine fighting
corruption and one of the aspects of
corruption the Ukraine was supposed to
fight was getting rid of the prosecutor
who may or may not have been
investigating Purisima the oil and
natural gas company on which Joe Biden's
son hunter Biden was sitting he was
sitting on the board
taking down 50,000 dollars a month for
basically being a person with the last
name Biden according to the Associated
Press
Democrats have zeroed in on the State
Department in the opening phase of their
impeachment investigation the
intelligence Oversight and Foreign
Affairs committees have already
interviewed Volcker a former special
envoy to Ukraine who provided the text
messages at least two other witnesses
are set for depositions this week Gordon
Sunland the US ambassador to the
European Union and Murray Ivanovitch who
is abruptly ousted as the US ambassador
to Ukraine in May now Volkers testimony
did not actually help president from a
whole hell of a lot there are some
people who are trying to spin it that
way it helped Volker
because what Volker said is listen I
didn't talk to the Trump administration
about Biden in fact I told Rudi that I
thought that the Biden stuff was way
overblown and I encouraged the United
States to work with Ukraine to root out
corruption and to get them their aid but
Volcker didn't actually say that he
hadn't that nobody inside the
administration ever said anything about
Biden he never suggested that that
Giuliani was not whispering sweet
nothings into Donald Trump's ears in
fact Volker sort of suggested the
opposite he sort of suggested that Rudy
Giuliani as the chief envoy to Ukraine
basically for the Trump campaign was in
fact the go-between that the Ukrainians
were having to please
right so Volkers testimony was not
particularly helpful
Gordon sunland he's gonna be showing up
to testify the reason Gordon Sunland is
important is because bill Taylor who was
the acting US ambassador to Ukraine
texted Gordon Sumlin and said this
sounds like a quid pro quo to go after
Biden and Gordon someone texted back no
that's not true give me a call
Democrats presumably will hone in on
that and suggest that the reason that
someone wanted this to be a call as
opposed to a text message is because he
was going to explain offline that maybe
in fact this was in fact a quid pro quo
to go after Joe Biden and finally Murray
ivanovitch who was the US ambassador to
Ukraine
she was ousted and the claim has been
that it's because she was not going to
pressure the Ukrainian government to go
after Biden although that is still again
unclear because she was a osted based on
general belief that she was a a pro
democrat person who was not particularly
loyal to the Trump administration and
you have to understand that a lot of
what President Trump does on a daily
basis is coming from a
of security in his own administration
it's coming from a belief that inside
the administration there are people who
are leaking against him which is true
there's a belief that there are people
inside the administration who are
looking for excuses to come after him to
undermine his presidency that's kind of
true and it does make one suspicious if
it turns out that this is now that what
the third whistleblower inside of a week
and a half who's now using the
whistleblower status in order to pump
some sort of quasi scandal into the
public viewpoint without proper
information being made public in the
first place according to the Associated
Press Trump and his supporters deny that
he did anything improper but the White
House has struggled to come up with a
unified response no administration
officials appeared on the sunday news
shows to defend the president while
other Republicans focused mainly on
attacking Democrats a few Republicans
suggested that Trump was only joking
this past week when he publicly called
on China to investigate the Biden's well
as we will discuss in just a little
while there is a reason why Republicans
are not appearing on national television
and it is not really fear of the media
it is feared that President Trump will
reverse course on them in a matter of a
heartbeat and then they'll be stuck
holding the short end of the broom and
things are not gonna go great for them
at that point they'll go out there
they'll defend president Trump and then
he will just go on Twitter and
completely blow up that defense he has
done that repeatedly president Trump
himself is tweeting here at the great
scam is being revealed he wrote this
away painted himself as a victim of the
deep state again there may be a case
that there people inside his own
government who are who are militating
against the success of his
administration after all the the FBI was
in fact investigating him for two years
on the Moller stuff and came up with
basically nothing that was that was
criminal in terms of behavior Trump also
decided to go after Nancy Pelosi he
tweeted out Nancy Nancy Pelosi knew
of all of the many shifty Adam Schiff
lies and massive frauds perpetrated upon
Congress and the American people in the
form of a fraudulent speech knowingly
delivered as a ruthless con and the
illegal meetings with a highly partisan
whistleblower and lawyer
this makes Nancy nervous every bit
nervous Nancy every bit as guilty as
little Adam Schiff he always puts it
like a little apostrophe at the end of
little witch that's not how English
works little Adam ship for high crimes
and misdemeanors and even treason I
guess that means that they along with
all of those that evilly colluded with
them must all be immediate
impeached okay he also would later go
after Chuck Todd as we will see in just
a few minutes so president this is the
real reason why Republicans are sort of
all over the place with President Trump
the answer is because how exactly are
they supposed to defend the guy who has
a series of shifting defenses every five
seconds it's very difficult
imagine that you're a Republican who
went out there like you know what
President Trump
definitely definitely was not calling on
governments to investigate Joe Biden
specifically and then the next day he
comes out he's like I would like for
China to investigate job and
specifically it's good what are we
supposed to do with that if you're a
Republican but you in such an awkward
position you know get two more of this
in just a second we'll get to again why
the Democrats seem to be so reliant on
whistleblowers and part of the reason is
because they think there's criminal
activity inside the administration
that's the obvious reason then there's
the non-obvious reason which is they
won't use their investigative power as
members of Congress instead they're
waiting from people inside the
administration to militate against the
administration from within which is
driving Trump's paranoia which in turn
is driving him to believe in certain
conspiracy theories that he is then
seeking to justify that he's seeking to
evidence by sending people like Rudy
Giuliani to Ukraine we'll get some more
of that in just one second first phone
bills they can cost you an absolute
fortune I mean just hundreds of dollars
a month and this is where mint mobile
comes in they can cut your bill down to
fifteen bucks a month for the same
premium coverage you're already getting
I know what you're thinking it's too
good to be true but these guys know what
they are doing they have the mobile
service by the way has the same coverage
that you're gonna get with any of the
major carriers here is really what
they've done they've cut out the
middleman because they sell online and
too they also understand that you're
actually not using that unlimited data
you're paying for unlimited data and you
are only using a fraction of the
unlimited data your old Wireless pay
bill pays for expensive retail stores
and overhead mint Mobile has cut out the
middleman and they make it easy to cut
your wireless bill down in just fifteen
bucks a month also by allowing you to
choose from a variety of different
choices in terms of the amount of data
that you actually want to use you can
use your own phone along with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide text and talk
plus crazy fast 4G LTE if you're not
100% satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their 7-day money
back guarantee to get that new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mint mobile.com slash pen that is
mi NT mo bi le comm slash pen mint
mobile comm slash pen go check them out
right now so as I say the Democrats are
over the moon about this whole whistle
blower thing dr. Allison stranger has a
piece in The New York Times today called
why America needs whistle blowers they
are not partisans but stewards of our
constitutional democracy well sometimes
they're partisans sometimes they're
stewards of our constitutional democracy
and sometimes they're both the question
is what are these whistle blowers and
the it's just not true that everybody
who claims to be blowing whistle is
doing a grand public service sometimes
the person blowing the whistle is
alleging a crime that doesn't actually
end up being fulfilled right this is why
Trump is so paranoid about people inside
and this is why he was putting his
conversations his transcripts with
foreign leaders in this classified file
this electronic file that nobody was
able to get access to why because there
were people inside his administration
who could run media every five seconds
that by the way has prompted a federal
judge to order the White House to
preserve a wide range of evidence about
president Trump's dealings with foreign
leaders including his interactions
related to Ukraine that have fueled an
impeachment investigation in the house
US District Judge Jamie Berman Jackson
issued the order on Thursday directing
the White House officials not destroy
records of meetings phone calls and
other communications with foreign
leaders the judge's order also appears
to specifically address reports that the
Trump White House set up a special
system to limit access to certain
records of presidential conversations
with foreign leaders Jackson of course
is an appointee of Barack Obama it is a
very weird thing by the way to suggest
that the White House has to preserve
records of foreign conversations with
with foreign leaders like that that is a
strange thing it's one thing to suggest
that if they are under subpoena you have
to preserve the records it's another
thing to suggest that they have to
preserve the records even when they're
not under subpoena and see like I think
it's probably a good thing as a general
rule that these things are preserved but
if the idea is that the executive branch
must turn that stuff over to the
legislative branch I'm not sure that's
always the case the President does have
plenary power over foreign policy
whether you're Barack
assigning a crappy deal with her on or
whether you are Donald Trump saying
ill-advised things to foreign leaders
meanwhile the Democrats are expanding
their rage against William bar who's the
Attorney General obviously there's a
piece in The Wall Street Journal today
talking about Attorney General bar going
to various foreign capitals to seek help
in reviewing the origins of the u.s.
counterintelligence investigation begun
during the 2016 presidential campaign
and this is where we start getting into
this very dicey territory and a lot of
people on the Left today and they keep
saying why are so many Republicans not
just saying impeach already why aren't
they saying impeach already and the
answer is twofold one you actually have
to prove the elements of the crime and
two you also have to prove that the
elements of the crime committed are
beyond any crime committed before by a
president that was not used as the basis
for impeachment in other words there is
the legal standard for impeachment which
is basically anything and then there's
the criminal standard for impeachment
which is he must create it and commit a
crime and then there's the James Comey
standard for impeachment remember the
James Comey when he was talking about
Hillary Clinton he said listen yes
intent was not an element of the crime
of misuse of classified information but
our history of prosecution suggests that
we don't have any similar cases like
Hillary's where we actually went forward
with prosecution precedent suggests that
she not be prosecuted and people like
maybe said whoa hold up that's not right
you're supposed to stick with the
statute okay well that is that is
generally true I will however point out
that there is a case who made that what
Comey was saying was at least correct in
terms of prosecutorial discretion and
when you're talking about impeachment
there talk about impeachable offenses
here's the reality
nearly every president commits some sort
of impeachable offense I mean there's a
good case to be made that Barack Obama
the IRS droning American citizens like
that there's a lot of stuff that Barack
Obama was doing that at the very least
fell into the category of criminality
right whether it required more proof to
actually prove it for impeachment
purposes probably but a man wrote an
entire book called the People vs Barack
Obama where I talked about the various
activities that bordered on the criminal
inside the Obama administration was he
impeached over any of that no so in
order for Democrats to now claim here's
the thing
in order for Democrats to claim that
Republicans should get on
for an impeachment what they must show
is not merely that a crime has been
committed they must show that the crime
is different in kind than anything that
they justified themselves right that was
the difference between the Nixon
activities and activities by prior
presidents the fact is that were prior
presidents like a I believe LBJ actually
bugged Barry Goldwater's headquarters in
64 but the reality is that was proved
with Nixon the cover-up was proved with
Nixon and Republicans said listen this
is beyond anything that we've actually
seen before us a word jumping on board
Democrats are holding a standard and
that standard should be upheld we saw
with Bill Clinton committing perjury
that it was completely it was completely
partisan there was nobody on the
Democratic side of the ow who actually
supported the impeachment of Bill
Clinton but Republicans at least could
make the case that the president had
committed perjury and this was a new
standard of low so you need two things
you need to prove one criminal activity
in my opinion right again this is all
opinion because the fact is you don't
have to prove anything for an
impeachment and impeachment is
completely political the the provisions
about impeachment say nothing about
natural crime being committed it's as
high crimes and misdemeanors but that is
a political term with that said I think
the standard for impeachment should be
twofold one criminal activity occurred
and we can all agree criminal activity
occurred and two that criminal activity
was so far and above beyond what had
come before and was not the basis of
impeachment that it justifies
impeachment that would be the twofold
standard so when Democrats are going
after attorney general Barr and saying
that attorney general Barr is doing
something deeply wrong in talking with
foreign allies to review the origins of
the Trump Russia investigation and they
say by meeting directly with foreign
leaders rather than relying on
investigator to investigate her channels
mr. Barr has stirred up domestic
politics in some of the countries he has
tapped for assistance because he talked
with Italy and he talked with Australia
and people were getting super uptight is
that impeachable stuff I struggled to
see why it is considering that three
Democratic senators earlier this year
called on the called on the government
of Ukraine to cooperate with the Muller
report and in fact investigate
allegations regarding Russian election
interference so when it comes to
impeachment if you want to bipartisan
impeachment then it really does have
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander in other words it's got to be
some sort of standard that rises beyond
partisanship and that is exactly what we
are not seeing at this point from the
Democrats first of all we don't see the
full extension of the crime because as
they say in order to prove the crime
here and reprove the quid pro quo that
is criminal in nature not just a quid
pro quo but a quid pro quo for something
criminal you have to prove that it
wasn't about corruption at all it was
just about getting Joe Biden everybody
Giuliani is very awkward human being I'm
Rudy Giuliani did in fact make this
points and listen we have a mandate to
investigate corruption and just because
Joe Biden gets caught gets caught up in
that does not mean that Joe Biden is the
target or that it is improper to
investigate Joe Biden in the first place
no not at all there's nothing wrong with
doing it I mean the fact is the
president United States has every right
to ask countries to help us in a
criminal investigation that should be
undertaken that happens the radical
opponent well I can't help that I mean
suppose the political opponent committed
murder what are we gonna do he's a
political opponent so you don't
investigate him okay
look there's some truth to that it is
also true that Joe Biden is not the
nominee Joe Biden is Natha nominee the
trunk the Obama administration actively
investigated poem anaphora in Ukraine
they didn't stop that investigation when
Paul Manafort became the Trump campaign
manager in fact they intensified the
investigation into the Trump campaign
overall they didn't go to Trump and
warned him didn't sit by the way your
campaign manager he's under
investigation
for the possibility of criminal activity
in Ukraine instead they broadened out
the investigation to include the entire
Trump campaign right to include Trump
himself so before we get into like this
is something completely different in
kind I don't really see how it's
something completely different in kind
unless unless unless this thing we this
is what we have yet to see unless this
thing was solely about getting Joe Biden
and it was not at all about corruption
I'll show you another example in a
second of the media trying to pretend
that certain activity that maybe
something you don't like is somehow only
bad when one side of the aisle does it
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about Halloween it's
on the way which means it's time to
break out rubber spiders and fake
cobwebs and jack-o'-lanterns and also
think about
death because that's what Halloween is
about well now that you're thinking
about death let me just say to have life
insurance because if you're thinking
about death and you don't have life
insurance well you are being a dum-dum
because you do in fact need life
insurance and this is why you should try
policy genius.com policy genius is the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in just minutes you can compare
quotes from top insurers and find your
best price once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance and auto insurance
and disability insurance they can do all
of these magical things just for you
well since it is the time of the year
when you're getting ready for Halloween
and thinking about wolves and demons and
your own moldering corpse well maybe now
would be a good time to prepare for that
eventuality with a little bit of life
insurance go be an adult go to policy
genius com get quotes apply minute you
do the whole thing on your phone right
now and then you can enjoy the candy
because hey if you die early from some
sort of horrible blood sugar overdose at
least you're gonna be taken care of
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance go check them out
right now ok so as I say one of the
reasons why Republicans are not jumping
on the bandwagon is because every piece
of news seems directed toward ignoring
Democrats doing sort of the same thing
so let me give you a perfect example big
headline from NBC News today Trump
blames energy secretary Rick Perry for
Ukraine call it sensor of impeachment
inquiry
it's a president Trump is madder Rick
Perry why because Rick Perry was pushing
for the call why was Rick Perry pushing
for the call because he wanted to open
up natural gas and oil development in
Ukraine to the West why does this matter
because then the AP has a piece called
profit not politics what some Trump
allies did in Ukraine quote as Rudy
Giuliani was pushing Ukrainian officials
last spring to investigate one of Donald
Trump's main political rivals a group of
individuals with ties to the president
and his personal lawyer were also active
in the former Soviet republic their aims
were profit not politics this circle of
businessmen and Republican donors touted
connections to Giuliani and Trump while
trying to install new management at the
top of Ukraine's massive state gas
company their plan was to then stir the
lucrative contracts to companies
controlled by Trump allies according to
to people with knowledge of their plans
the effort to install a friendlier
management team at the helm of a gas
company called
still DAWs would be taken up by
Ukraine's new president with Ukraine's
new president by US energy secretary
Rick Perry who slate of candidates
included a fellow Texan who is one of
Perry's past political donors now you
may be saying to yourself hold up a
second am I supposed to be suspicious of
Rick Perry because Rick Perry has
friends who are in the Ukrainian natural
oil and gas sector and maybe are using
dropping names in order to get ahead
what if I switch that name for you and
instead of Rick Perry just said Joe
Biden are we allowed to be suspicious
anymore or does the suspicions disappear
poof we're supposed to pretend it's not
suspicious at all when hunter Biden ends
up with no oil or natural gas experience
pulling down 50 grand a month because
his daddy is the vice president of the
United States right like that is that
really is it like this is why people are
going nuts like Oh case you're gonna
tell me it's super corrupt when friends
of Trump are doing business in Ukraine
with oil and natural gas but when it's
Joe Biden's son then we're supposed to
pretend that none of this matters at all
like at all at all we're supposed to
pretend that Joe Biden is pure as the
driven snow and so is hunter Biden and
any questions you ask about them are
fully illegitimate now again for the
1,000th time if Donald Trump has no
evidence and no serious questions to be
asked about Joe Biden or hunter Biden
he's just going after them for political
purposes by leveraging military aid to a
country under the threat of the Russians
in order to go after his political
opponents solely and completely because
of not corruption and not because of
2016 and the election interfere does not
have any of that but simply because he
doesn't like Joe Biden not only is that
wrong that's impeachable but are we
there yet and I think we have a ways to
go there first I do find it somewhat
hilarious you get people like Cory
Booker who says that the minute you
asking a question about Joe Biden it is
it is completely unfair according bucker
which show is he on returning member he
said that if you asked even asking
questions about Joe Biden is unfair at
this point if you could just stop it
stop asking those questions
what are questions about hunter Biden
fair in the context of a president who
is accused of doing
really what I would think were
unimaginable things as I said it's
shocking me is it ant questions about
hundred Biden in this context somebody
who has been investigated somebody who
from the Ukrainians to the Americans to
Europeans there's no evidence whatsoever
so no it is not fair
that the President of the United States
is trying to get all of us to be talking
about someone else other than him okay
and then it'll be fun to watch CNN
immediately ships in the next segment to
let's talk about Rick Perry's energy
connections in Ukraine guys let's talk
about the Trump administration's energy
connections in Ukraine and by the way
the Washington Post will give a full
op-ed to Joe Biden called Trump won't
destroy me and he won't destroy my
family and it's all about how Joe Biden
is a wonderful dude and anybody who
asked questions about hunter Biden is
just wrong and it's all mean and it's
all terrible he's his end to trump and
those who facilitate his abuses of power
and all the special interests funding
his attacks against me please no I'm not
going anywhere you won't destroy me you
won't destroy my family come November
2020 I intend to beat you like a drum
come to member 2022 you are gonna be
eaten earlybird dinner at Denny's
because you are not the nominee
Elizabeth Warren with this nomination so
that is not a thing that is going to
happen okay I'm gonna get back into this
double standard and again it's not what
about ISM it's very bad for Trump's who
say things like China should investigate
Joe Biden it's very bad for Trump to say
that Ukraine should investigate Joe
Biden and not be clear that he's talking
about corruption more broadly the
question is twofold did he commit a
criminal act to is that criminal act
impeachable wreck is not every criminal
act is impeachable so we're gonna get
back to the double standard which sets
the standard for that second question
right
is this something brand new and beyond
the pale and why Republicans seem to be
kicking back so hard against the idea
that this is something brand-new and
beyond the pale it's funny Democrats
seem to believe that the world began
spinning with Trump and see how these
articles today about well the the
unworkability of American government and
this feeling of cynicism that has spread
across the country I'm old enough to
remember a president before him named
Barack Obama some of us are pretty
cynical about politics because of that
sort of manipulation we'll get some more
of this in just one second first
sometimes you just need to pray okay
not just on politics but you know just
on life prayer is something that I do
thrice
daily in fact I'm about to spend an
entire day at prayer on Yom Kippur
prayer is very important to my life
because not only does it help comfort
you and give you an ability to focus and
and create for yourself the the intense
sort of agenda for it for the coming day
it helps you coordinate with something
beyond yourself and this is why we here
at the Ben Shapiro show are partnering
with pray calm and is the number one app
for prayer and sleep both anxiety and
sleep sufficiency can do serious damage
to your brain and your body
high stress lack of sleep they make you
more prone to accidents weight gain
depression with pray calm he will
discover a new daily and nightly prayer
routine as well as inspirational Bible
stories designed to strengthen your
faith and lift your spirit they got an
Old Testament they've got a New
Testament they got all sorts of good
stuff
here the bible come to life through
stories like adam and eve Noah in the
ark and the Ten Commandments as part of
your daily prayer routine on pray calm
right now Ben Shapiro listeners get 60%
off a pray calm Premium Subscription
by downloading the pray comm app and
pray calm at /ban that is pra Y comm
slash been over fifty million prayers
have been created on pray calm find out
why at pray calm slash been okay in just
a second we're gonna continue discussing
these double standards and the media's
outrage at Republicans who refuse to
immediately cave in - it's time to
impeach it's time to impeach by the way
fast Amy Klobuchar Democrat in the
Senate about whether she would impeach
and she was like I'm not gonna answer it
we'll get to that in just one second
first you have to go over to Daily wire
comment subscribe for $99 a year you can
get this the greatest and beverage
vessels see it we are on the road this
is the leftist year's hot or cold
tumbler we have a deactivated the
cloaking device just so you can see it
and thus you can look gaze upon its
beauty and understand that this is the
kind of vessel you would love to own so
go check that out right now over at
daily wire.com get the $99 subscription
really helps us how it helps protect us
from the vicissitudes of the nasty left
seekingcindy platform us and destroy our
show so please join the team
we're the largest fastest core and
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say when you're talking about
the the double standard in which the
left engages let me give you an example
so John Brennan I mean this is just
insane so john brennan the former head
of the CIA he was on the news over the
weekend being newsy and i don't even
know why exactly this dude is considered
a reliable pundit in anyway he's done
Meet the Press and he says the CIA would
literally not assess America as a
democracy any longer and we're supposed
to take John Brennan seriously about
this this is gaslighting of the highest
order we would look at it as a very
corrupt government that is under this
way right now of this powerful
individual who has been able to just
corrupt the institutions and the laws of
that country what you say about the
stability of the democracy I think it's
no longer you know a democracy if an
autocrat is has it in his hands and
people like Johnson and others are putty
in his hands which means that the
democratic principles upon which this
country are founded are eroding right
now okay they're eroding you know what
tended to Road the democratic principles
when you lied in front of the Senate
repeatedly in 2014 John Brennan who is
the CIA director of item fatica Lee
according to Victor Davis Hanson and the
CIA had not illegally accessed the
computers of US Senate staffers were
then exploring a CIA role in torturing
detainees liberal senators started going
after him and Brendan had to apologize
in May 2017 as an ex CIA director he
again almost certainly did not tell the
truth to Congress when he testified an
answer it's representative Trey Gowdy's
questions that hadn't he neither knew
who had commissioned the SEAL dossier
nor had the CIA relied on its contents
for any action then he spent two years
claiming that he had secret information
that the other shoe was about to drop in
the Russia investigation like that dude
did more to undermine confidence in
America's institutions than virtually
anybody in American public life for the
last five to ten years and yet you got
Chuck Todd that that wonderful apex
media creation a creator yeah you Deming
Chuck Todd just really sterling stuff
over the weekend saying you know John
Brennan there's just a follow up about
that you know you when he talked about
destruction of American institutions
were you instrumental in any of that mr.
mr. right nope it's why is everyone so
you John Brennan why are people so mean
to you do you understand how we got here
and and how would you explain to
somebody you've been completely
character assassinated and eviscerated
and it doesn't matter whether people
like you or hate you I think know
everybody we can agree you've been put
through this you understand how you got
here come on that was the question that
was the question that led to oh then now
the institutions have been letter right
again you think the Republicans are
immediately going to cave - yes I think
that the Democrats are not pursuing a
partisan impeachment I think they're
being completely aboveboard is in any
Amy co-op achar the senator from
Minnesota running for president she was
asked straight up would you vote to
remove the president from office today
and even a man kalapa chair was like I'm
not sure I can say that because a Mihkel
avatar is the only non crazy person
running for president Jake I have been
very clear I think this is impeachable
that the case should be heard by the
house and it should come over to the
Senate now I don't know what ping counts
are gonna have or how they're gonna do
this okay so again she's kind of unclear
there no know exactly what's gonna
happen there maybe it'll be this maybe
it'll be that now we get to the
Republican response now over the weekend
the big hubbub of course was that
Republicans were apparently just
covering for Trump now here is the
biggest problem for Republicans and it
is a problem there's a very the most
convincing defense of President Trump is
that President Trump says dumb crap
repeatedly that has always been the most
convincing defense of President Trump
you know why because it is highly
plausible you know how we know that cuz
we watch him cuz we hae has a Twitter
account in which he doesn't spell things
correctly and in which he's spell in
which he capitalizes random words
Cait says dumb crap repeatedly is like
it's it's pretty much as mato writes
like on his business card until I became
famous like what are we talking about
and yet and so when it comes to scandals
when it comes to President Trump came up
with a plan the plan was deployed Rudy
Giuliani to uncover the specific
corruption of Joe Biden and then
leverage the Ukrainian government to
help rajul eonni to go after the
specific corruption of Joe Biden because
the man he has a gimlet-eyed sharp-eyed
steely steely missile man I'd plan he is
just going to carry that here's the best
of
No right this is the best the best event
is no you gotta be kidding no that's
this is not a dude with a plan and the
problem for Republicans is to say that
that's the problem for Republicans is
that if you're a Republican senator and
you say that Trump might attack you
print like go after you so instead you
have to somehow plan that you have to
say this is all for T chest but the
problem is if you say it's 40 chest then
he's capable of seeing what he's doing
and if he's capable of seeing what he's
doing it makes him look more guilty not
less guilty so here's the thing as every
good defense lawyer knows there are a
few defenses that are available when it
comes to crimes of intent hey and when
it comes to a bribery situation like
this like a bribery case that they're
trying to make or a quid pro quo or a
targeting case which is what they are
talking about an abuse of power you sort
of require intent as an element of the
crime the quick answer for defense where
is intent was not here there was no
intent the intent was not present and
here's the beautiful thing about Trump
as a client the intent is almost never
there because Trump doesn't have
requisite intent for nearly anything the
man has the attention span of a gnat
that doesn't mean that he can't actually
do wonderful things as presidents and
many wonderful things that I appreciate
it's why I'm more likely to vote from
now than I was in 2016 I get all that I
get that he's delegated a lot of stuff
that's great he's done a lot of things I
think no other Republican would do
sometimes it's great that he's punching
back at the media all of that is granted
taken for granted if you are his defense
lawyer his best defense - he had a plan
in Ukraine to go after Joe Biden is dude
doesn't have plans here's the evidence
he doesn't plan things ever when is the
last time Trump had like a four-step
plan
he just doesn't rate instincts great
politically no plan and this is why I'm
gonna give you an example so Jim Jordan
the Republican from the house from Ohio
he was on with what was it with with
Chuck Todd was it and Jim Jordan
and Jim Jordan yeah sorry who's that
with Stephanopoulos rather and Jim
Jordan he was asked about Trump's China
comments now the obvious answer to
Trump's trying to comment says dude says
a lot of dumb stuff right there's a lot
of dumb stuff
like my first response was right and he
asked for and he asked for the DOJ to
investigate Netflix because Obama signed
the deal with Netflix and then he asked
the DOJ to investigate SNL and the FCC
to investigate us and now like come on
like if you asked Trump any random
country like if you just put if you said
to him five minutes before he went out
on the South Lawn the the country of
Malaysia you'll just be like I share
Malaysia should investigate Biden why
not why not I don't know if I didn't
didn't Mele like it doesn't matter to
him he doesn't care it's just somebody
had said to him that Trump that the
biden did something corrupt in china and
so he mentioned Biden in China the
answer is there's no plan right Jim
Jordan has two tries to say that but
when it comes off as is Jim Jordan
saying that he's joking but that's not
what Jim Jordan even means
George you really think he was serious
about thinking that China's gonna
investigate the Biden family he said it
right there and probably I think I think
he's getting I think senator Rubio said
a couple days ago he's getting the press
all spun up about this remember this is
the president who's been tougher on
China than any other president he wants
to make sure China to quit stealing
America's intellectual property he wants
to make sure they start abiding by
international trade norms okay know what
Jordan is saying here well I presume
represented Jordan is saying here is
true it's also not the convincing
defense right he starts off right and
then he doesn't go to the obvious place
when he says you think he was serious
there you think he was here then he's
like he's really tough on China that
wasn't the answer the answer was you
think he was serious there was the last
time you heard president from being
serious about investigating anybody he
said that people should investigate
Nancy Pelosi Adam Schiff Hillary Clinton
the congressman from Elijah Cummings
said Elijah Cummings should be
investigated he said SNL should be
investigated Netflix shouldn't be
investigated right he has said that he I
believe he has said that that the NBA
should be about like he said pretty much
every major organization in the United
States should be investigated that's the
proper answer here so this is the one
where you choose to take him super
seriously George like you know better
than that right that's the proper but
the problem is Trump watches TV
so if Jordan says that and Trump might
tweet out against Jordan right and you
get this from all the Republicans so
Republicans are not allowed to make the
proper defense right they're not allowed
to make the proper defense and so they
ends up
this kind of weird Neverland where
they're making half the proper defense
and half than that proper defense so
here is Senator Ron Johnson with Chuck
Todd so this got all sorts of press over
the weekend because apparently Johnson
was just in over his head and Chuck Todd
just just destroyed him because this is
what journalism is all about you've got
John Brennan on you you ought to ask
director Brennan what did Peter struck
mean when he texted Lisa page on
December 15 2016 Anna DeWolfe canwe
scorned and what does this have to do
with Ukraine their kid their kid it has
everything to do with Ukraine now listen
talked about nine senators I ain't no
idea no that's dancer set up to this
point why a Fox News conspiracy
propaganda stuff is popping up on here
is no I okay the reason okay so what
Johnson is trying to say in that whole
exchange if you should watch the whole
exchange what he's trying to say is
President Trump is very upset with with
members of his own administration or in
the executive branch who keep leaking on
him and so he's taking stuff and he is
putting stuff basically in a in a secret
vault said they came out Likud and he is
also deeply suspicious that there are
members of the Intelligence Committee
who are coordinating with whistleblowers
and he is deeply suspicious that members
of the intelligence community are not
working
on his behalf with regard to the
investigation of interference in the
2016 election in Ukraine which we do
know happen according to Politico in
2017 and so that's why he's deploying
more DG Lanyon right that's what Johnson
is trying to say but chuck todd has his
questions that he wants to ask and so
Chuck Todd is gonna ask those questions
no matter what now with all of this with
all of this said is Trump in an enviable
position anywhere here no no no this is
an viewable right that we already know
that President Trump has done things
that are not good the question is
whether they are in the criminal
territory and whether they are in the
unprecedented territory and when it
comes to an precedented that one is
actually even easier than criminal
because for a lot of Republicans the
answer is absolutely not for a lot of
Republicans they're looking at the fact
that Hillary Clinton worked with the DNC
and the Ukraine
Embassy to try and dig up dirt on Donald
Trump and they funneled a bunch of bad
information to the FBI to Barack Obama's
FBI in the middle of the election cycle
they're looking at the fact there's a
two-year investigation of Donald Trump
by his own intelligence services they're
looking at the fact that the Obama
administration did not let up on Paul
Manafort when it found out that Paul
Manafort was gonna become Trump's
campaign manager and didn't warn Trump
about it instead they broaden the
investigation to include Trump again all
of this is backdrop for do we think that
your partisan hacks or do we think that
you honestly are bothered by drum now
motivations normally should not matter
but when it comes to impeachment they
kind of do the reason being if you are
trying to build a bipartisan consensus
then people have to feel that there is a
standard and the standard must be upheld
on both sides it can't be a standard
that is upheld on one side as I say if
you have a double standard then you have
no standard because nobody is going to
abide by a double standard if you feel
that somebody else's is not playing by
the rules
why would you play by the rules and that
is where we end up right now that is a
separate question from when from whether
Trump actually did something criminal
that question is still outstanding that
one is the one that is still outstanding
and by the way it doesn't help when
President Trump goes after Mitt Romney
you know the the media are trying to
conflate by the way Republicans who are
critical of Trump on the China comments
and on the Ukraine comments with saying
that they would vote for impeachment
Mitt Romney has never said that he would
vote for impeachment
you know Trump should just yell what the
fact that he said something bad about
China it is bad to call on the Chinese
Communist to investigate an American
citizen based on scant the evidence we
had a DOJ for that
I mean Lindsey Graham is right about
this he says listen we have a special
counsel we could have a special counsel
investigate Biden if we really want you
why the hell are we going to foreign
countries this is correct
well let's look at it this way everybody
said Muller would be an independent guy
and I think he was and what happened he
cleared Trump there was no collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians and why do we know that because
Muller spent two years and twenty five
million dollars looking at it as anybody
looked at the DNC Ukraine connection no
they have not
now loved Rudy Giuliani he's a good
lawyer for the president he's defending
the president's interest but the Moller
investigation is over it's not released
to find out if the Biden's did something
did something wrong I'd like somebody
outside of politics to look at the
Biden's like Muller looked at the
Trump's remember the Trump Tower deal
with Russia yeah that was looked at by
Muller somebody needs to look at the
Biden's regarding the Ukraine and China
okay that that is not out of the realm
of possibility nor is that improper one
of the big problems here is that the
Trump campaign can send rudy guiliani
where they want to dig up op o obviously
Hillary Clinton said the same thing did
the president in his in his capacity as
president basically act as campaign
president and dictate that the the
auspices of the government should be
used to do Rudy Giuliani's dirty work
and that's really what this is all about
that remains the open question okay time
for a quick thing that I like and then
anything that I hate so things that I
like so as you may notice I am NOT
broadcasting from my usual studio I am
instead over here in Israel an
unspecified location so I that means
that I did I'm looking a little Pekin
that is because I was just on a 13 hour
flight with a five year old and a three
year old which means I got no sleep and
I'm kind of tired so if I've been
bumbling and stumbling over my words a
little bit today that is because I'm
half dead but that also means that I
watched 1,000 movies on the plane
because it's a 13-hour flight one of the
movies that I had a chance to watch was
a movie that I like to call Liam Neeson
has it done which is like every Liam
Neeson movie basically and I will watch
all of them because I don't really care
what he's doing as long as Liam Neeson
has a gun in this one Liam Neeson plays
a man who has a gun and in this movie he
is a man who has a gun who is the father
of a man who does not really have a gun
in doesn't know how to use a gun here is
a little bit of the trailer for run all
night
it's gotta be in 15 years since I've
been in here place Lexus affronting all
the old places look different now I'm
the only one ever cared about you and
all that ended an hour ago when you
killed my son okay so the the movie is
actually quite good Joel Kinnaman has
become one of my favorite actors I
really like Joel Kinnaman a lot David
they've talked about him a little bit
for bond possibly he was in Hana which
is a pretty good series and he was also
in the killing where he is a completely
different character and then in this one
he plays sort of a an upright citizen
who's the son of a drunk hit man who is
Liam Neeson's character the movies
pretty good I'm not gonna say it's like
I'm an incredible movie but it is a a
fairly good movie and I think worth the
watch or maybe I was just up all night
man I would watch anything so go check
out run all night if you are up all
night and have nothing else to watch
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so you know people are always
proclaiming that corporations should
involve themselves in politics and
corporation the Democrats people on the
Left they they want it both ways on the
one hand corporations should never
involve themselves in politics ever ever
ever ever they should stay out because
corporate heads who are involved in
politics are bad bad humans on the other
hand their silence is deafening on LGBT
rights their silence is deafening on the
animal rights movement right every time
there is some sort of political
controversy we have to hijack major
corporations and use them to cram down
particular political agendas here is the
fact major corporations are after the
cash and that means that very often they
have no actual moral interest and
treating them as moral entities is quite
silly in fact and the proof of this
comes this this week from the NBA so
apparently the general manager of the
Houston Rockets according to the New
York Times sought to quell an outcry in
China on Sunday night after the support
he expressed on Twitter for
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong
upset sponsors and media outlets and
basketball officials in a country that
invest billions in the NBA the initial
and quickly deleted message by the
general manager Daryl Morey on Friday
night to stand with Hong Kong put the
NBA at odds with its largest and highest
priority international market but he
tried to MIT
the damage with two clarifying tweets
from Tokyo where the Rockets are
scheduled to play two exhibition games
against the Toronto Raptors I did not
intend my tweet to cause any offense to
rocket fans and friends of mine in China
Mori wrote I was merely voicing one
thought based on one interpretation of
one complicated event I've had the
opportunity since that tweet to hear and
consider other perspectives in other
words the NBA called him not very angry
at him because they thought that he was
threatening their Chinese market by
talking about the fact that the Chinese
communist regime is evil and terrible
how dare he how dare he I've seen other
corporations like for example Google go
out of their way to try and work with
the Chinese government even if it means
doing their dirty work for them now this
is why when people say big business is
Republican big businesses for free
markets no big business is for profits
profits very often can be had with the
cooperation of big government in fact
big government and big and big business
are not actually at odds in many cases
it is big business that is propping up
big government and vice versa so the
just gonna point out here that Gerald
Maury said the right thing he got
blasted by it by the supposedly all
moral NBA and nobody seems to care all
that much about it like where is where
is Adam silver now like why isn't Adam
Silver being called on the carpet by the
American people for not standing with
Hong Kong by the way just because he
wants to sell a few more sneakers and
basketball jerseys in China alrighty we
will be back here tomorrow with all of
the latest I'm sure there will be a lot
there hopefully I'll have had some sleep
and won't slow my words quite as much
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo
white house key edited by Adam Tsai
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua all Vera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Klavan show one of about a
million ways politics makes a stupid is
by attacking people's personal
peccadilloes as a way of supporting
massively destructive ideas Donald Trump
is a loudmouth so let's get rid of him
and give the country to baby-killing
socialists who hate both the first and
second amendment luckily I'm here to
laugh uproariously at that idea plus
nois and I will discuss Joker be there
on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clayton